jetzt wünsche mir gespannt ob ich je mit
hatten unterschied schmecken und ob das
wirklich geschmeckt hat glaubt gekommen
war nur ein video
leute ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich hab
mir heute also das ganze passiert so ein
bisschen im block format ich bin nämlich
gerade aufgestanden wir haben jetzt
moment muss nur kurz nach 14 uhr als ich
bin schon um halb zwölf aufgestanden ist
wachsen zu frühstücken und jetzt wertlos
meiner habe ich noch diesen tisch
aufgebaut also die wohnung nimmt langsam
form an die tische steht auf rang drei
ist auf jeden fall einige anstrengende
schon wieder möglich war gefühlte
zehnmal unten den müll wegbringen also
in diesem fall stress ist nun jetzt
folgendes ich habe mich heute was bei
uns überlegt ich wollte dass wir mal von
einem halben jahr machen also bin aber
irgendwie nicht zu bekommen weil ich da
auch nicht in köln gewohnt hat und sonst
auf jeden fall habe ich gestern von
einem freund von mir mitbekommen wer hat
gesagt in köln hat sich aufgemacht da
gibt es halt so ausgefallen ist wird zu
ihren die sind auch etwas gesehen hält
auf jeden fall so ausgefallenere pizzen
wir sind auch etwas teurer
und ich habe mir gedacht hey du magst op
sooo gerne pizza ich meine welcher
andere mensch ist und eine pizza und wir
machen jetzt folgendes wir machen jetzt
den test und holen uns einmal eine pizza
für 10 euro und eine pizza für keine
ahnung 50 euro 40 euro ich bin gespannt
was da so hinbekommen wenn er persönlich
mehr gerne pizza hut deswegen würde ich
sagen
eine 52 15 euro und dann diese luxus
pizza ich nehme euch mit ich hab sofort
drauf und lässt
[Musik]
noch dazu schön ins mikrofon
ja es ist einfach so mega fan 26 auch in
diesem hause jetzt wohnt dass es mehr
große wohl kommt man sogar ist dann kann
ich einfach mein finger hier drauflegen
und das aber ich bin gestern gar nicht
gefällt mir dort auf jetzt haben wir nur
ein kleines problem wie soll ich hier
irgendwo die kamera drauf stellen
mussten dinge gesagt dass wir nicht
funktionieren also wir dann vielleicht
wieder
[Musik]
2000 mal ganz wichtig kann ich nur raten
wenn ihr euren führerschein habt immer
handy weg ich stets rat einer ampel
deswegen kann ich jetzt mit filmen aber
ich will auch sonst eigentlich nicht
film während der fahrt okay leute zieht
es in den wie gut gepackt naja ok so
besonders ist es jetzt auch nicht aber
das auto ist so mega lang ich glaube es
ist fünf meter lang soll ein bisschen
schwer damit eine parklücke zu kommen
wenn man da vorne und auto gefahren hat
was nicht so lang war bzw
nicht so weit so leicht wollte er zwar
diese luxus pizza für leute kleines
problem ich wollte dass gerade diese
fette holen die halt ein bisschen teurer
ist das ding ist diese scheiße gemacht
jetzt besitze nur auf warum auch immer
ich meine wir sind in köln
wieso hat man hatte ich mittags auf die
andere die andere und dann kann ich
endlich nach außerhalb zu machen also
notieren wir zwei sitzen und jetzt geht
eigentlich nach hause und spaß ich bin
glaube ich in 15 losgefahren und die
familie sitzt 30
[Musik]
so weit geht ohne sprach ich hab mal
hunger jetzt ich hab nur gefrühstückt
hat schon 18 uhr
diese zeit schon kalt diese ist
eigentlich aus frankreich
also irgendwie habe ich alles falsch
nummer zwei zu trinken
so wird für diese fünf euro betrag und
diese pizza 39 vergessen
ich hoffe ihr glaubt mir das ich ist mir
wichtig meine zeit habe ich meine das
jetzt schon etwas luxuriöser autos hier
aber die verbittert eine absolutistische
sagen wir mal ich weiter wie geschmiert
geschmack auf der zunge um ihn zu
vergleichen
schreibt doch jetzt einfach mal euer
liebling setzte und in die kommentare
das interessiert nicht mehr guck mal
zusammen meisten leser wo ich liebe
diese person okay leute bereit wäre
jetzt verwehrt wie gedacht ich weiß sie
nicht mehr
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob ich ihnen
karten unterschied schmecken und ob mir
das wirklich gut schmeckt die fertigkeit
auseinander
ich muss einfach sagen die beiden
öffentlichkeit sind hier und da zeigt
sich mehr so gut ist er ich werde
jederzeit gut die wert vom basteln
wirklich alles zum rand schmeckt
wirklich echt heftig also sitze ich habe
das mit verkäufen gesprochen ich laufe
nicht als wenn wir dies ich war sehr nah
gekommen sind meinte jung hat meine
tiere füttert schmeckt echt guten die
sich jetzt fragen jo alle klassen an
dieser platte als anormal schützen
um ehrlich zu sein keine ahnung was ich
aber sagt der schinken schmeckt echt
mega gut und da kann man echt richtig
nichts schenken und soweit der krise so
komme ich auch was mit ist bei rechte
biss sagt die man jetzt vielleicht
mittag einfach mal zu essen sollte für
39 euro
kann ich den titel 15 oberstaufen ich
habe sechs euro trinkgeld gegeben ab 50
euro
hamas gelernt mein bundes aus und dann
haben wir 50 euro ich würde sagen ein
stück würde ich sie frage ich etwas
mache ich damit natürlich eine tiefe
kann ich jetzt brauchen die andere wäre
es niemals schaffen soja beladene
fahrzeug vergessen das wäre eigentlich
ganz wichtig vor allem bei so einem
video also erst mal kann ich sagen ich
meine die pizza hat jetzt 40 euro kostet
die andere part 5 euro gekostet auf
einer skala von 1 bis 10 villiger pizza
vom pizza hut ohne achtgeben und der
anderen pizza ich meine die war echt
mega mega geil und wenn sie jetzt zehn
euro kosten würde ich vermutlich immer
nur noch dieses wissen aber sie
konstatiert sich euro ich würde sagen
dass es von sonders sehen nur dass dinge
zeit das teil konzentriert sich euro an
die leute heraus und echt mega gerne
pizza essen wenn ihr eine großstadt
wohnen und die möglichkeit habe man
wirklich sonne richtig richtig krasse
pizza zu probieren
dann macht das aber wenn ihr pc
nicht so gerne mögt dann investiertes
geld wird in irgendwelche anderen dingen
ansonsten war es echt witzig und ich
meinen wechseln sagen er hat mit pizza
für 40 euro probiert aber ich denke ich
werde meinen guten freund auf jeden fall
treu bleiben und ich hoffe der flops ist
eigentlich mein blog hat es gefallen
wenn ja das war vielleicht noch machen
soll stopps in die kommentare
mit was natürlich kann man es noch mit 1
man kann es mit
irgendwie kann man hier mit einfachen
jedenfalls sind und wir sehen uns dann
morgen weil ich wieder raus rein raus